Forget by the way we're doing this good
day Las Vegas viewer cookbook we're
putting it together online and it's all
of your favorite recipes that you can
share with the other viewers of this
wonderful delightful program share your
favorite recipes with us picks pix
8newsnow.com and then we will post them
to the cookbook which will also be on
8newsnow.com we've gotten some
submissions this comes from an m
lionelier
langolier in
Green's going to talk to you about that
I know this is my mom she submitted a
recipe for butternut squash and apple
soup topped with goat cheese and pumpkin
seeds oh my gosh that has been a staple
of our Thanksgiving as long as I can
remember she serves them in little
pumpkin uh bowls
yeah put the seeds in you there's a
little dollop of the goat cheese you
stir it around so have you learned how
to make it no I've learned how to eat it
though quite a bit so submit your
recipes as well we want to see them mama
langler I was looking for a good soup
recipe for Thanksgiving this year
you can stand your spoon up in it yeah
okay yeah but it's good that's okay
well if you ever have leftovers you can
bring them here just saying